okay the Louisiana troll has come out of
the out of hiding out of the woodwork I
don't know what you want to call it but
the Louisiana troll called in and
apparently missed my story about Hillary
Clinton's new book and is I guess
expecting me to recommend Hillary's book
because as far as he knows I think
everything Hillary does is great which
is weird because I have been slammed the
last week because I've been criticizing
Hillary take a listen to this what up
David chilly willy Pac Man I was just
wondering when you're gonna recommend
the book what happened to your audience
no I know you like recommending books
and I know you really like Hillary
Clinton so Wow
when are you gonna do it like the big
old guys released this book this was
great and are you voting for her again
in 2020 question thank you who could
watch the show and think that I just did
this big fan of Hillary Clinton I don't
get how somebody could watch the show
and come away with that it's really
really weird and by the way is that my
voice when I recommend books hey guys I
want to recommend this book to you how
is that even my voice it's weird no I
don't I don't buy it I don't get it
we've got a tremendous bonus show for
you today I mean truly folks truly I am
hearing that this is the best bonus show
that we've done if you are a coffee
lover you don't have to worry about Pat
forcing a Keurig on you you do have to
worry about climate change impacting
coffee production we will talk about the
funny little incident involving ESPN
sideline reporter Sergio dip and we will
also talk about middle-class incomes
middle-class incomes and 2016 two ways
to get access to the bonus show there
used to be just one way four years there
was one way to access the bonus show
which was membership there are now two
ways membership and patreon very very
exciting folks I'll tell you patreon.com
slash david pakman show david pakman.com
slash membership will speak to you on
the bonus show